hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast early days of the NIH brain
initiative I am Judy our our code lab
roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
presentation has been approved for a
category 1 continuing medical education
credit by Loma Linda University if
you're interested in obtaining CME's
after attending this presentation please
click on the get your free CME credits
button in the bottom left corner of the
event screen this webcast is designed to
be interactive and we encourage you to
ask questions during the event you can
submit questions like typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you have any technical problems viewing
or hearing this presentation please
click on the support button at the top
right of your presentation window or
submit your problem through the green
Q&A button lower left I would now like
to introduce today's speaker dr. Wolk
Walter Cora shets dr. Corey Schatz was
named acting director of men's in
October 2014 prior to this appointment
he served as deputy director of min
since January 2007 where he worked with
the nihms director in program planning
and budgeting and overseeing Institute
scientific and administrative functions
before joining mins dr. quartet served
as vice chair of the neurology service
and director of stroke and neuro
intensive care services at Massachusetts
General Hospital MGH it was also a
professor of neurology at Harvard
Medical School and has led neurology
resident training at MGH since 1990 a
native of Brooklyn New York
dr. quartets graduated from Georgetown
University and received his medical
degree from the University of Chicago he
trained in internal medicine at the
University of Chicago and Massachusetts
General Hospital dr. quartets trained in
neurology at MGH after which he did
postdoctoral studies
cellular neurophysiology at MGH and the
Harvard neurobiology Department he
joined the neurology staff first in the
Huntington's disease unit and then in
the stroke and neuro intensive care
service I will now turn it over to dr.
Cory Shep's for his presentation oh this
is dr. Walter courgettes and it's a
great pleasure to talk to you it's
evening here
very relaxed time to communicate to you
a very important topic the National
Institutes of Health brain initiative as
Judy mentioned I'm the acting director
of the National Institute of
Neurological Disorders and Stroke one of
many Institute's at NIH that fund and
conduct research in neuroscience the
brain initiative is a unique initiative
on the part of NIH as it did not come
from NIH originally it came from the
President of the United States the White
House recognized the need for advancing
neuroscience research and put forth this
initiative which is to advance brain
research through advancing innovative
neurotechnologies so it's a very neuro
Technology driven project and unique to
the NIH at this point the NDS as I
mentioned is one of many institutes that
funds neuroscience research and in fact
neuroscience research receives the most
funding of any general category at NIH
approximately 5.4 billion dollars per
year are coded as neuroscience research
this research is done throughout
multiple Institute's our Institute is a
hundred percent neuroscience research
there are other institutes which are
heavily neuroscience research such as
the National Institute for mental health
the National Institute of drug abuse and
then other Institute's have varying
degrees of neuroscience portfolios such
as the National Institute of Aging
which is charged with developing better
therapies for Alzheimer's disease but
also aging research in general National
Institute of Child Health and
development for instance funds research
and development of the nervous system
and these Institute's although they work
individually with their own priorities
and portfolios come together and what's
called the neuroscience blueprint at NIH
and that group is very much invested in
the brain initiative and much of the
support for the brain initiative has
come through the blueprint in addition
to additional funds from congressional
budget to NIH for the purpose of
advancing the NIH brain initiative I
imagine that many of you who are
listening tonight or this morning or
wherever it is wherever you are around
the world recognize the draw
that understanding the brain has for
millions and millions of people around
the world the brain is inherently
interesting because it is really the
physical basis of who we are as humans
who we are as individuals so we can
gather the imagination and the interest
in curiosity as an example of that the
media has certainly taken advantage of
this interest in terms of bringing out
to the public the messages about the
brain and the new brain science in the
United States of those going into pH
beep programs the largest percentage of
PhD students are entering neuroscience
and this is growing compared to the
plateau that have seen in many of the
other science areas so neuroscience is a
growing field and the brain initiative
is really trying to develop the
technologies that can arm these new
investigators coming into the field to
make greater advances in the science of
how the brain functions now as I
mentioned the brain is inherently
interested interesting to many millions
of people around the world but there is
a very real reason why it should have
interest to those interested in the
public health as well and that's because
if one looks at daily adjusted life
years of disability disorders of the
brain are the leading cause of
disability in the US and actually be in
most developed countries and is growing
around the world even in the developing
countries neuropsychiatric disorders and
neurological disorders combined are the
leading cause of disability followed by
cardiovascular and circulatory disorders
and those actually include stroke which
in our vernacular is considered a
neurological disorder neoplasms come
third musculoskeletal sword is fourth
and many of the musculoskeletal
disorders are characterized by pain as
their main feature and those can also be
considered coming under the rubric of
neuro neural disorders so I think
there's a huge burden of illness that
people are suffering with due to
disorders of the brain and the nervous
system
and these disorders the symptoms the
problems that they caused are related to
abnormal functioning of neural circuits
so let me explain that for a second so
for instance in the condition of a
stroke is an area brain that is damaged
but what matters to the person is not
necessarily area that's damaged but the
symptoms the things that they can no
longer do because of that brain damage
and that's related to the circuit
function in the brain when the damage
occurs there's orphan maximal disability
but all the time the circuits become
better able to function and most
patients with stroke who survive will
develop improved function over time and
that's because the circuits in the brain
are rewiring and function is improving
and those patients in whom function does
not improve the circuit changes are not
translating into improved function so
the point here is that it's the circuit
behavior the circuit activity that's
linked to the behavior the circuit
activity and the malfunction of that
circle activity is what is most closely
related to a patient's deficits and the
burden of illness so at the center of
trying to help patients is understanding
the circuits of the brain how they
function in normal individuals and how
they disavow their what is the nature of
the dysfunction and those people with
neurologic or mental health or even
substance abuse disorders so the point
here is that circuit activity is key and
that it is and disordered neural
circuits are responsible for a large
burden of illness around the world
not only of these disorders disabling in
an individual person but one of the
reasons they account for so much
disability around the world is because
they often start at a younger age and so
the disability is lifelong as opposed to
conditions which occur later in life
this is true certainly for all the
developmental disorders and we consider
things like autism mental retardation
multiple different genetic disorders
that affect development to the brain as
this group of disorders that affect and
cause disability throughout the life of
an individual and that's one of the
reasons these brain disorders of account
for such a large percentage of
disability if one looks at Alzheimer's
disease and these other disease of aging
which lead to dementia it's another
reason why we are very worried about the
burden of illness due to neurological
disorders as the populations age in the
United States and the other developed
countries Alzheimer's disease and
dementia become a much much larger
problem and actually put serious strains
on the ability to care for the affected
individuals as the numbers increase and
again the example that I used before
with stroke I want to come back to and
that is that when one looks inside the
brain of an elderly individual there are
signs of Alzheimer's disease but there's
a disparity between the degree of
involvement and the patient's deficits
and that's because the biology that's
that's ongoing inside the brain
the Alzheimer's biology is affected
there the effect on the
patient is mediated by how that affects
changes in brain circuits and for
reasons we really don't understand some
individuals seem to be resilient and
their circuits function better than
others leading to less severe problems
with cognition and memory the point
again being that the Alzheimer's biology
is causing trouble to patients because
of its because of the way it affects
brain circuit function whether it be
memory or planning speech again the
circuits are central attention and the
reason I'm going to concentrate on the
circuits because the brain initiative is
focusing on those tools which will allow
us to monitor interrogate and modulate
neural circuits
so to summarize brain disorders both
neurodevelopmental and neurodegenerative
we think will be the most disabling and
most costly of the chronic diseases they
will be in the 21st century what
infectious disease was in the 20th
century and the key issue is brain
circuit function and we have to confess
that we do not know enough about how
brain circuits function and how they
dysfunction to caused disability for
persons with neurological mental and
substance abuse disorders so we can
examine someone for their ability to
remember but we can't actually see those
memory circuits in action and know what
is the deficit and those persons who
have trouble why certain persons with
stroke develop incredible ability to
recover function by rewiring brain
circuits after injury and what others
can't
while some elderly individuals even with
significant evidence of Alzheimer's
biology in the brain a death have been
functioning at a high level where others
have been exceedingly disabled what we
need to be able to do is to examine and
see these circuits in action be able to
monitor them over time be able to see
the circuit changes that occur years
before the patient experiences
disability and then to understand how to
correct these circuits orders to restore
function and the individual who's
affected our problem is that we do not
have the tools to be able to examine and
monitor circuits of the brain in
real-time and that is the main issue
behind the brain initiative it is a tool
development project and we're brought to
this very prescient concept by Freeman
Dyson that new directions and science
are launched by new tools much more
often than by new concepts the effect of
a concept revolution is to explain old
things in new ways the effect of a tool
driven revolution is to discover new
things that have yet to be explained and
the purpose of the brain initiative is
to fire up a tool driven revolution that
will give us the tools to be able to
interrogate neural circuits and modulate
them for health and we believe that this
is an appointed time where this endeavor
has a great chance of success and that
is because progress in neuroscience and
technology is yielding new insights into
brain structure and function so shown
here is a picture
of an MRI scan using a technology called
diffusion-weighted imaging to be able to
map out the connections that occur
between brain regions seen here in blue
and red
prior to this ability it was impossible
to see any definition of structure in
the white matter which is the region of
the brain actually the largest region in
the human brain and which there are
axons connecting the different brain
regions the actual structure behind the
circuits but MRI technology in the last
30 years has advanced to the point where
this is now possible it was never
possible before indeed this was a
breakthrough in structural connect omics
the connections between the circuits in
the brain but there are also amazing new
technologies and optics genetics in the
combination of opposites and genetics
nanotechnology informatics to help us
design new tools that can interrogate
the nervous system at the speed of light
the speed of thought to be able to
capture neural activity as is occurring
in behaving animals with the hope that
this can be translated to human studies
in the near future so these are it's an
exciting time where technologies that
have come from basic science discoveries
and creatures called a chi AR CH AI e
who are too primitive to be called
bacteria but have channels that activate
when light is shone upon them taking the
gene from these primitive organisms and
introducing it
with promoters into transgenic animals
or with virus loaded genes into the
brain these channels can be then
expressed in the membranes of neurons
and light can then activate these
neurons in a very specific manner this
is light years away from the more crude
technology of activating neurons which
is to send an electrode into the brain
and then turn current on which has
dramatic effects but very hard to
understand exactly what that very crude
wire conducting electricity is doing
optogenetic techniques allow very
precise activation or inactivation of
particular neurons in the brain an
advance that has already revolutionized
how people just do science and then led
to amazing better understanding of
neural circuits what's next is a good
question when it comes to neuro
technology as a neurologist who first
came into medicine in the late 70s I was
introduced to the CT scan to look at
brain structure seen here is a 1974
picture of the brain you can see some
white around the edges where the skull
is and a little bit less bright in the
cortex and a little darker in the white
matter and then a very dark area in the
ventricles which are filled with CSF
fluid and this was an amazing to be able
to this was amazing to be able to see
the brain like this in 1975 but it's
laughable now because the details are
lost of
what the brain really looks like compare
this to high field MRI scanning seen
here on the right side of this image and
the detail is quite spectacular so this
is a period of about 35 years where will
technology take us next is the question
for the brain initiative and there is
every expectation because we're spoiled
that new technologies will give us much
greater insights into brain structure
than ever before but the brain
initiative hopes to go past structure
and to actually see brain activity brain
function in real time as well and that's
what the president put out in April 2nd
of 2013 goal that the next great
American project some people call it a
moonshot into the brain comparing it to
President Kennedy's challenge to go to
the moon this is a challenge to unlock
the brain by as the president said
giving scientists the tools they need to
get a dynamic picture of the brain in
action to better understand how we think
how we learn how we remember and I agree
that that knowledge will be
transformative the brain is
is much bigger than NIH it involves
other federal agencies such as the
Defense Department's Advanced Research
Program the National Science Foundation
and the Food and Drug Administration it
also includes
private foundations such as the Howard
use Medical Institute the Allen
Institute for brain science
the cavalry Foundation and the Simons
Foundation each of these groups have a
slightly different approach to the brain
initiative but we are working together
among the federal agencies and the
private foundations to leverage the
investments and maximize the output the
NIH brain initiative is built upon a
brain 2025 scientific vision that was
put together by the Advisory Committee
for the brain initiative to the director
Francis Collins the director of NIH that
group held community consultations in
many different areas around the country
on particular topics that are relevant
to the brain initiative I would
encourage all of you interested in this
area to read this document which is
available on the brain initiative
website at NIH because it laid out a
vision for how the goals of
understanding monitoring and modulating
brain circuits are within reach with a
significant investment of effort funds
and time over the next 10 to 12 years
focus as I hinted many many times
previously in this talk is to map the
circuits of the brain to measure the
fluctuating patterns of electrical and
chemical activity flowing within these
circuits to understand how their
interplay creates our unique cognitive
and behavioral capabilities my and I
might add to use this knowledge to
understand diseases of the nervous
system I mentioned this when I first
began speaking that the disability that
patients with neuronal and substance
abuse disorders suffer is a direct
result of the disordered brain circuits
because this brain circuit function that
is translated to motion thought speech
personality everything that we are to
understand that we need to be able to
see the circuits in action so we can
understand how the brain forms memories
for instance to determine how the
therapeutically modulate brain activity
one example is the improvement of motor
control in Parkinson's disease which has
already been done using the very crude
wire and electrical current injections I
mentioned earlier quite a dramatic
example of how injecting current into a
particular area of the brain can turn
someone who's a mobile with their
Parkinson's disease into someone who's
dancing in the room it's an example of
how modulation of brain circuits how
powerful that can be we need to
understand the circuit act dysfunction
and how to modulate it for benefit in
the other disorders not only
neurological disorders but the
psychiatric disorders the neurologic
disorders have known pathologies that we
can try to address but for the neuro for
the mental health disorders and the
substance abuse disorders there is no
known pathology it's purely a circuit
dysfunction so in those disorders
understanding brain circuits is critical
the goal is to see this brain activity
within the precision of individual
circuits and at the speed of thought the
brain 2025 roadmap gave us seven
high-priority research areas which I'd
like to review for you now the first of
these is called discovering diversity if
one thinks of the brain is a computer
and it is a computer it is the most
amazing powerful computer more powerful
many times more powerful than anything
that man has been able to construct but
to understand a computer you need to
understand its components and that is
what discovering diversity is about to
identify and provide experimental access
to the different brain cell types these
are the cells that compose the circuits
so these are the elements of the circuit
itself we saw in that diffusion MRI the
connections between different brain
areas different brain regions in red and
blue those were the axons coming from
particular cell types and we need to
understand the different types to
characterize them and to determine their
role in health and disease the brain
computer is a very complex one at that
the circuits occur at different levels
they occur on a microscopic level where
one cell is connected to a nearby cell
or a cell a few millimeters away but
then there are connections with areas of
the brain that are very far away from
that beginning nerve cell and
addition there are multiple networks
within the brain that act in concert
with each other so there are really very
many different levels of brain circuit
function and activity that are ongoing
continuously in our brains and so we
need to understand the circuit diagrams
at these multiple different levels at
varying resolution from the synapses
that connect one cell to the other to
the network that occurs in a nucleus to
the network that occurs among many
nuclei in the brain to the entire brain
itself and that is what we call mapping
the brain circuits at multiple scales
third which is mentioned many times that
we need to see the brain in action the
brain is dynamic the activity is
changing continuously a static picture
of the brain is an incomplete picture so
we need techniques that can be applied
to improve our methods for large-scale
monitoring of neural activity as it is
occurring continuously we have a
technique called functional magnetic
resonance imaging which sees the changes
in blood flow that occur in brain areas
as they are activated but the brain
activity is occurring on a millisecond
basis these changes in blood flow are
occurring at on a matter of seconds so
there's a huge delay between the brain
activity and the blood flow change and
so this technique has severe temporal
resolution trouble that we need to get
better techniques to get better temporal
resolution fourth is demonstrating
causality so one can look at brain
activity in many ways but and one can
correlate it with behavior
but to actually know that a certain
brain activity is actually causing the
behavior takes another level it takes
the ability to intervene in the brain to
make a change in that neuro sacred to
see what the change in behavior really
is and it's only by linking an
intervention to a change in brain
circuit function and then to behavior
that we can really say we understand
what causes that behavior so
demonstrating causality is closely
linked to being able to intervene to
turn on nuclei or turn off nuclei as
mentioned say with optogenetics v
high-priority research area is under is
identifying fundamental principles to
produce conceptual foundations for
understanding the biological basis of
mental processes through developing new
theoretical and data analysis tools the
point here is that we have not had the
ability to measure neural activity in
thousands or tens of thousands or
millions of neurons simultaneously so
the fundamental principles are based on
what we can measure which are generally
the activity of one neuron or a couple
of neurons once we get into this new age
where we can see brain circuit function
at this much deeper level we are going
to need no new tools to analyze this
data and it will lead to fundamental new
ideas about how brain circuits function
and that's what is meant by identifying
fundamental principles many of the
techniques that are being developed are
really only able to be used in animals
at this point and to record from all
neurons in a nervous system
during a behavior
only a we were only able to do that in
very primitive organisms such as
zebrafish potentially in Drosophila next
and then maybe in the mouse but the goal
of this is to advance human neuroscience
so we can work from the inside out from
the most detailed controlled situation
and work our way until we understand
everything and then move into the human
but the brain initiative is also asking
us to also start with the human use the
technologies that we have now in more
innovative ways develop improvements in
those technologies or new technologies
that will give us a window to the human
brain such as the MRI has done in the
past so the brain initiative is moving
from the inside out and from the outside
in and the focus the eventual goal is to
create and support integrated human
brain research networks and understand
them so we can better understand and
treat its disorders and from brain
initiative to the brain the idea here is
that we want to do what the technology
is to take it to the point where we are
learning new things about these
important brain functions that are
really very difficult for us to measure
now such as cognition emotion perception
and action and health and disease so to
take the technology to understand
circuit function and its dysfunction so
that those are the seven major points
that the brains 2025 scientific vision
put out for us as goals for scientists
in the United States and around the
world to reach for to develop the
technologies to be able to put the ball
across the goal line and achieve in
these seven areas
the first five years is expected to be
heavily weighted on technology
development because the questions we
want to answer need new tools once those
tools are developed the plan then is to
move more heavily into discovery driven
science using those tools to answer
these very important questions the
investment that was recommended in the
brain 2025 report is seen here the total
is seen in black so it's investment that
ramps up over time to approximately 500
million dollars per year by FY 19 as
mentioned as seen in blue the early
investments will be heavily in tool
development in neuro technology and then
over time more of the investments should
go into actual use of those tools to
answer neuroscience problems and this
needs to be supported by infrastructure
for tool dissemination for data sharing
and for moving the entire scientific
field forward important to mention the
technologies coming out of the brain
initiative should be valuable to a broad
swath of neuroscience it's not for
particular regions of neuroscience but
for the entire scope of neuroscience we
think can benefit from these tools
coming out of the brain initiative where
are we today in
20:14 NIH invested 46 million dollars in
58 projects across six different funding
opportunities it funded a hundred
investigators on these teams in 15
states and three countries in 2015 we
expanding to almost 80 million dollars
with ten different funding opportunities
in the reach in the areas that were
mentioned previously as outlined in the
brain 2025 report the hope is that we
will receive what was proposed in the
President's budget 135 million in FY 16
to get us closer to our targets
so in summary brain disorders are a
leading source of disease burden and
cost in the US and around the world
recent breakthroughs and new
technologies are transforming how we
study brain structure and function yet
we are still lacking the tools we need
to be able to monitor and modulate
intervene in brain circuits for the
benefit of health the brain initiative
builds on the recent progress to create
tools that will accelerate discovery and
build the foundation we need to reduce
the burden of brain disorders I hope
that this was informative that intrigues
your interest into the brain initiative
into how the brain functions into the
ability of new tools to open windows
into the brain and to use those tools to
understand brain disorders and how
better to develop treatments for them
I'd be happy to answer questions at this
time thanks very much for your attention
thank you dr kourosh it's for that
informative presentation before we get
started on the question-and-answer
session I would like to remind our
audience how to submit questions you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can and our first question is is the
brain initiative currently focusing only
on understanding normal circuit function
or are you looking into disease brain at
the same time good question the NIH
brain initiative is concentrating in
both of those areas in truth but at this
early stage the emphasis is on tool
development technology development there
are however projects that we hope to
launch very quickly in which new
technologies can be used in patients
undergoing neurosurgical procedures such
as deep brain stimulation for
Parkinson's disease or intracranial EEG
monitoring for persons with epilepsy to
better collect data on brain activity in
those regions where neurosurgeons have
put devices and put hopefully new
devices that are coming out of the brain
initiative to learn better
what is the abnormal circuit function
based on the brain activity measurements
that they're making and also
better to intervene with brain
stimulation so for instance we have
projects which bring companies that
develop would develop cutting-edge new
technologies in these neuro surgical
areas will work we'll be working with
our scientists to better understand
brain function and how to improve it in
people with these disorders I hope that
answers the question thanks very much
please give us some idea of the tools
being used or developed currently
question mark for example molecular
biology or imaging or electrophysiology
or bioinformatics etc yes well there are
a large number of tools that have come
into the fore a say in the last five
years and I'm going to be remiss and not
mentioning them all
I did mention optogenetics and that is
incredibly useful now in studying what
happens when certain nuclei in the brain
are turned on or turned off that
involves placing optical catheters into
the brain and this means animals to turn
on a light that will then activate the
channels that have been introduced into
the nuclei of interest that either turn
them on and turn the more there is
another technology called dread
technology that's extremely interesting
somewhat parallel to the optic genetics
but they are a gene has been introduced
with a receptor
and that receptor does not activate with
any known neurotransmitter but instead
activates artificially when the animal
is given a drug the drug that's been
used mostly so far is clozapine it's a
it's a clozapine analog called CNO in
the rodent
it's very inert in the human it actually
does metabolize the clozapine which is
an anti-psychotic so it has actual
biological effects but recently through
the brain initiative investigator brian
ross group in north carolina has
developed the ability to activate this
receptor with a drug that is inert and
as mentioned by giving the drug then the
neurons in which this artificial
receptor have been introduced can be
either turned on or turned off giving us
control not necessarily from an optical
catheter and the inside of the brain but
from a drug that we can be given
intravenously or orally so that's an
example of a movement of the technology
in this area in terms of brain recording
techniques I mentioned deep brain
stimulation where wires are placed into
the brain currents injected in patients
with Parkinson's disease
these wires are now being developed to
have recording capabilities as well as
stimulating capabilities this will
enable continuous data to be obtained
from people who wanted to go this
therapeutic procedure so we'll have
data on brain activity in this region
where the wire is and that can be
correlated with behavior and correlated
with the current injection the
intervention that's made there are also
great advances that have been made in
the brain computer computer interface
world where very tiny chips have been
introduced in the brain
enabling recording from one or a few
neurons per per projection but these
chips can have hundreds of projections
enabling recording from hundreds of
thousands of neurons the power of this
has certainly been seen in cases in
which this brain electrical activity has
been used to control computers or
prosthetic devices what we've seen here
is that the neural activity coming out
of the brain is a mirror on how the
brain learns because when first put in
the neural activity cannot control the
device or the computer but the brain
learns how to do that over time so by
collecting this information we see brain
plasticity in real time so these are
just a couple of examples that are new
that we could add on to the MRI scanner
the high field MOR functional magnetic
resonance imaging magneto
encephalography intracranial Econ
recording of neural activity so yes
there are there have been many advances
and that's why we believe the time is
right to because these are stepping
stones to something even more miraculous
so thanks for that question
reports our DBS is working for
Huntington's question mark have you been
testing that more if it's helpful well I
think I was actually a neurologist who
took care of many Huntington's patients
over the years and I have not been aware
of DBS as a very effective treatment for
the disability that occurs in
Huntington's disease Huntington's
disease unfortunately affects large
areas of the brain multiple different
networks and connections there is a mode
of control disorder that's similar to
Parkinson's with slowness in
coordination this Korea which is an
involuntary movement but the biggest
problem is actually motor planning so
patients with Huntington's disease have
much have a great difficulty learning
motor control programs to do play the
piano wash the dishes and they they lose
these motor programs over time so the
the problem in Huntington's is very
complicated throughout multiple circuits
and would be very difficult to turn that
around by stimulating one brain area I
think where deep brain stimulation has
shown a lot of promise but still in the
investigative stage is in depression so
patients with depression that are
resistant to medications have been
helped by turning off of particular
brain region with deep brain stimulation
and so these disorders where there's a
central control region that is spreading
out into large areas of brain such as
the dopamine cells in the [ __ ] which
then release widely into the stratum
there's an example where stimulation
looks promising and depression similarly
there may be certain control centers
we're changing the activity in that one
center can have a massive effect but in
things like Alzheimer's in Huntington
disease the disorder is really quite
distributed throughout the brain thanks
very much for that question though which
are the companies that are helping in
tool development
another good question I hope they all
will it's actually something we're
actively working on is engaging industry
in the brain initiative so we've had
discussions with companies as far afield
as brain imaging companies to the
companies that develop intracranial
recording and stimulation technologies
to the companies that are involved in
managing and analyzing the huge streams
of data that come out of the brain when
one measures brain activity and
thousands of neurons simultaneously so
we think that there is a great interest
on the part of private industry to
become involved in the brain initiative
but I think it's a work in progress
aligning the different agendas in the
private industry groups in the public
groups and for certain areas of the
brain initiative they're more relevant
to industry than others I think we've
had the greatest pickup in the area of
brain stimulation and brain recording
intracranial brain stimulation recording
in humans so thanks for that question
well brain initiatives the interested in
linking brain function disorder to
environmental exposure well I think
looking into the brain and understanding
brain circuits is the current frontier
the next frontier I think is what this
question is getting at and that is
understanding environmental influences
on brain function and that has been very
difficult as mentioned our tools for
interrogating and monitoring brain
circuits are quite poor our tools for
monitoring environmental exposure over
time and humans are worse so I think
that's another area of discovery and
tool development that's crucially needed
so for instance a disease like
Parkinson's disease there is a genetic
component but it accounts for a minority
of the percentage of causality in
Parkinson's disease so that means to us
that there is an environmental component
but how to get it back
certainly there are very tantalizing
natural experiments that happened the
most prominent was the use of a drug
called mptp by drug abusers in
California they were trying to make a
recreational drug and instead made a
chemical that destroyed the neurons in
the substantia [ __ ] and caused severe
parkinsonism a dramatic example of how
environmental exposure leads to brain
diseases in Parkinson's disease the
question has been for a long time are
there other
less potent but longer exposures to
toxins that lead to the disease there
are some clues that pesticides may be in
that category but we have a real problem
in interrogating the an integral of the
exposure to toxins to understand how
they work to disturb neural circuits so
I think coming together in the end
will be our understanding of genomics
our understanding of brain circuit
function and then bringing in the
environmental exposures to see how they
interact in this triad that determines
who we are and how our brains function
so thanks again that was a great
question unfortunately we are out of
time I want to thank the audience for
their interesting questions and
participation in today's event we also
like to thank dr. corsets for his
informative presentation today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
for several months following you'll
receive an email from lab roots alerting
you when this webcast will be available
for replay
I mean why you'd afford that
announcements your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event see you
next time goodbye